s'ils gagnent toujours devant
[Musique]
le bicycle à saramon élèves m'ont
demandé de valade de faire le concert
qu'on avait prévu de faire l'an dernier
il ya n'ouvrait fébrilité c'est vraiment
comme si on y était la salle sera vide
mais les conditions du direct devons
nous demander de tout donner comme si on
avait la salle pleine quoi c'est devenu
une évidence qu'il fallait le faire
contre vents et marées et qu'il fallait
repartir face au public via les réseaux
sociaux via facebook en live streaming
[Musique]
flore est beau en fait c'est une
succession de commandes hier de
d'émotion j'avais ressenti quand j'étais
en métropole parce que c'est là bas que
j'ai écrit mes premières chansons
les dix chansons qui sont sur l'album le
mot flore est beau en fait d'une
contraction de la dévise de la réunion
qui est qui veut dire je fleurir est
partout où je serai porter moi c'est
devenu mode devises
jdo
là mon envie
s'il faut on
s'ils donnent sens tu n'apprends 2
[Musique]
là
j'aurai la chance d'avoir nicolas payet
qui viendra chanter quelques chansons
avec moi sur scène thierry gauliris
m'accorde le privilège de venir aussi
donc on va interpréter quelques chansons
on sera épaulé par les ébénistes qui
sont instruits un trio de cuivres
m
moore
le soir
les jours
[Musique]
lamont
c'est le moment ou jamais de voir cette
grosse machine qui sonne vraiment très
bien qui voilà qui envoie du lourd pour
le coup et même si a pas de public dans
la salle on est persuadé que les gens
seront présents devant leur écran
regardez nous inviter des amis chez vous
par plus de 5
bien évidemment
faites tourner le message est promis on
se retrouve très bientôt
il est tout soit et tous les jours nous
rappeler à nos pitons l'amour